invité un speaker qui m'avait dit je ne
sais pas s'ils peuvent venir finalement
il peut venir et je
ému parce que quelque part on a dû
modifier notre d'autres programmes gérés
crise certaines choses et en reçoit ce
soir un intervenant exceptionnel il
n'est pas prévu sur le programme vous ne
l'avez pas dans vos plaquettes mais je
crois que c'est une vraie chance qu'il
soit avec nous ce soir sa venue il est
là et il s'appelle john turner
s'il vous plaît john si vous voulez bien
venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir john bonsoir bonsoir nous sommes
très heureux de vous accueillir ici ce
soir à belfort alors c'est vrai que les
français je sais pas si vous connaissent
je ne crois pas tout cas vous êtes
franco-américain vous vivez aux états
unis vous êtes un proche de barack obama
et du président joe biden vous avez
contribué activement à l'élection
d'obama en 2008 et 2012 et à celle
également de joe biden l'année dernière
quel parcours plus en plus vous parlait
très bien français
ma mère était française à l'est de paris
et à
la rencontre et mon père un jeune
militaire américain de son mari en
france et puis je suis arrivé et à l'âge
de 12 ans et on est tous repartir aux
etats-unis dans la ville natale de mon
père chicago d'accord et c'est dans le
cadre je crois de vos études
universitaires que vous allez faire une
rencontre qui va changer votre vie à
l'université
j'avais comme professeur de science
politique david axelrod qui conseille
aussi des hommes politiques influents de
démocrates aux états unis j'ai fait tous
mes stages chez lui ça a matché entre
nous d'accord et ensuite
axelrod vous propose un poste dans son
cabinet et c'est là que vous apprenez
votre métier de conseiller politique
vous accompagnez bon nombre de sénateurs
démocrates et en 2007 vous avez je crois
j'ai regardé 43 ans est là à 43 ans
c'est la rencontre avec barack obama oui
obama était client du cabinet de david
hasselhoff moi j'étais dans le bureau
d'à côté et un matin david me dit viens
un café j'ai quelqu'un que je présentais
c'est un barack obama et alors qu'elle
avait été votre impression à ce moment
là haut je le connaissais déjà de leur
réputation
comme sénateur
avocat
et david lui avais déjà parlé de moi
pour l'aider et je me rappelle encore
très bien barak m'a regardé très
fixement il m'a dit jordan idiot et là
on ne s'est plus quittés et on a
travaillé ensemble sur la la primaire
démocrate
janvier 2008 barack obama déclare sa
candidature à l'investiture démocrate
face à hillary clinton qui alors est
favorite pour les primaires mais c'est
vous qui gagnez
barak un homme intelligent avait voulu
une garde rapprochée il y avait david
hasselhoff nelson qui étaient ensuite
pas parle de la maison blanche j'en
faisais partie on a travaillé contre
hillary clinton on a à gagner et après
on a gagné
l'élection contre le le républicain john
mccain et c'est là d'ailleurs que j'ai
rencontré joe biden et on a continué
ensuite à travailler ensemble alors moi
j'avais entendu parler vous mais je ne
sais pas je pense que beaucoup de gens
ici ne vous connaissent pas on vous voit
pas dans l'immédiat pourquoi je suis ce
qu'on appelle
aux états unis ammann shadows un homme
de l'ombre montbrun donc je travaille
sur des dossiers
sensibles
et ma dernière campagne était celle avec
joe biden l'année dernière et ma ma
dernière mission je suis presque en
retraite c'est pour ça que je peux
m'exprimer
ma dernière mission était avec kamala
harris ou gta avec elle la semaine
dernière à paris et son mari c'est pour
ça que vous êtes en france votre
français pour excédent comme celui de
l'essai
vous allez sortir en décembre un livre
chez plon sur votre histoire et vous qu
écrivait une série pour netflix sur la
vie et l'ascension de barack obama qui
va s'appeler yes we can je crois
barack et michelle michelle obama très
très présente dans le couple ils ont dit
ok à netflix à condition que je sois
dans le dans le scénario parce que je
connais bien la famille est là le
véritable histoire
c'est pour ça je suis là très bien mais
je suis vraiment désolé parce que je
sais et encore vous avez d'autres paires
hâtif il ya un avion est sa vraie il
s'est vraiment arrêter ici aux côtés d'
x de belfort pour vous faire un petit
signe on a été un peu chamboulé en tout
cas attendez attendez attendez
jeu et on va terminer par une bonne
nouvelle oui je suis lâché l'âme la
grande nouvelle pour vous vous m'avez
donné l'autorisation de le dire alors
j'espère que ça va que ça ira mais par
l'intermédiaire de john
tenez vous bien michelle obama sera
présente l'année prochaine ou tedx de
belfort c'est ça
merci john wayne
à la halle cherche est une femme engagée
donc à la 10è leur fera
je compte sur vous merci encore et merci
au pape l'auditionner c'est vrai qu'il a
fait vraiment le passage et on s'y
attendait pas on a été un peu bousculée
là tout à l'heure
mille pardons chers amis
vous venez de vivre une imposture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne suis pas de jon turner vous l'avez
bien compris
je suis jean marc bonnet je sais c'est
c'est beaucoup moins fun
j'ai voulu vous faire comprendre ce soir
comment il était possible de se faire
passer pour un autre
cet exercice me permets de poser une
question faut-il croire suivre faire
confiance à celle ou celui qui est dans
la lumière qui parlent haut et fort
vous avez vu comme avec une mise en
scène la complicité de l'équipe du tedx
un petit pin's
un léger accent du middle west de la
charente maritime
et puis un peu de chance et un peu
d'insouciance
on peut se faire passer pour un autre
depuis la nuit des temps les imposteurs
et autres mythomane sévices avec brio
les arnaques n'ont pas d'âge tenet
rappelez-vous ce film avec gérard
depardieu le retour de martin guerre
tiré d'une histoire vraie en 1548 où il
joue le rôle d'un faux revenant de
guerre au début comme ce soir ça
marchait où ce jeune homme qui s'est
fait passer pour dimitri le fils disparu
d'une ancienne ardue russie ivan le
terrible
il est arrivé à monter sur le trône et
après aussitôt lui ça s'est mal terminée
à l'époque
alors aujourd'hui on pourrait penser que
l'accès à l'information
nous amènerait plus de vigilance et
limiterait ses impostures et bien non
elles sont
de plus en plus nombreuses ils sont
nombreux ces escrocs à qui on donne sa
confiance tellement ils sont
convaincants crédible charismatique il
maîtrise les techniques de l'acteur est
excellent dans l'expression orale ils ne
font plus qu'un avec leur double leurs
personnages
cette double personnalité parfois fils
frise le grand art il y a même des
champions du monde de l'imposture j'ai
pas si vous en connaissez et
rappelez-vous 1925 victor lustig qui a
réussi ce qu'aucun autre ne pouvait
imaginer vendre la tour eiffel
après une pression de guerrière
d'escrocs aux états unis il revient en
france dépensé son argent
dans le paris des années folles hélas
son magot fond comme neige au soleil il
ouvre le journal et les un article
sur la tour eiffel
la tour eiffel coûte cher à l'état elle
aurait dû être démonté en 1909 le
journaliste écrit doit-on vendre la tour
eiffel eurêka avec un complice il se
fait passer pour un haut fonctionnaire
du gouvernement et il invite 5
ferrailleur a déjeuné au crayon et leur
nid le gouvernement a décidé de vendre
la tour eiffel
elle va être elle va être démontée
et elle va être vendu comme ferraille
est l'
un des cinq
ferrailleurs cela ne s'invente pas un
certain nommé poisson
mord à l'hameçon
ses manières sont des ans le passer pour
quelqu'un de tout à fait crédible
quelques jours plus tard il s'aperçoit
de la supercherie
victor lustig a déjà quitté la ville
poisson ne dit rien par peur du ridicule
son épouse avait pourtant avait pourtant
quelques doutes
son mari aurait dû l'écouter plus proche
de nous
incroyable ce soi disant experts de
tueur en série est en fait un imposteur
il était aussi proche du duo guyane des
serial killers il sait tous depuis 40
ans il enchaîne conférences colloques
documentaires livres émissions de télé
émission de radio les journalistes lui
demandent mais pourquoi vous vous vous
intéressez à ces monstres assez tueur en
série il répond parce que j'ai vécu un
drame un traumatisme personnel la
première compagne s'est fait assassiner
il change les variantes 1 elle a été
étranglée
viol et découpé en morceaux
éviscéré
quand je suis rentré à la maison j'ai
découverte j'ai appelé la police les
enquêteurs m'ont fait part de leurs
investigations c'est comme cela que je
me suis intéressé à ces crimes en
réalité tout est faux il n'a jamais vu
un cadavre de sa vie
et le fbi a il n'a jamais entendu parler
de lui mais il n'y avait pas de raison
de ne pas le croire il était sur les
plateaux de télé
alors ces imposteurs pourquoi ils font
ça dans ce dernier cas un besoin de
reconnaissance
d'existence et puis victor lustig
l'appât du gain et ils sont nombreux
je vais vous avouer quelque chose j'ai
pris un plaisir inavoués à me faire
passer pour john turner
l'espace de quelques minutes j'étais
proche de barack obama
joe biden j'ai même vu chez certaines et
certains d'entre vous quelques regards
admiratifs
l'imposteur recherche si cela la lumière
être au centre de toutes les attentions
alors maintenant avec ça
que faire
qui croire
il faut donner sa confiance bien sûr
mais pas une confiance aveugle
gardons notre esprit critique
nous pouvons naturellement faire ce
travail d'investigation au quotidien les
imposteurs ont souvent été démasqué par
des personnes comme vous et moi mais
attention ce travail d'investigation ne
doit pas nous emmener vers le côté
obscur de la méfiance malsaine de la
défiance en continu qui nous isole
restons vert vers les autres et vers le
monde nous pouvons vérifier simplement
les informations qui nous arrive tenait
tout à l'heure j'ai glissé deux fausses
informations dans l'interview de mon ami
john turner j'ai cité nelson
monsieur olson ça vous dit quelque chose
c'est l'épicier de la petite maison dans
la prairie
et camilla harris je citais son mari
brian il s'appelle pas bariani s'appelle
douglas et sur sa fiche wikipédia quand
des événements ou des informations nous
arrivent essayons de prendre de la
hauteur de rester lucide dans une
stabilité émotionnelle
quand j'ai un doute je module de
réflexion
je dose mon esprit critique et je me
rapproche de ce qu'ils savent de ceux
qui ont la bonne réponse
je suis absolument convaincu
d'une chose nous sommes entourés de gens
formidables il y a plus autour de nous
de personnes sincères et d'experts
crédibles
que le contraire
alors à nous d'être attentifs de bien
regarder de bien écouter pour s'en
apercevoir
pour apprendre en transparence
et en confiance merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]